he took everything from me
first of all let me say this was like
late night viewing for me and y'all
bring it to us like from the first scene
it's like you're right in the middle of
that spy thriller and i'm just curious
for you
going into this knowing knowing that you
were going to expand this sort of tom
clancy universe
what you wanted to bring to this one
because john's a very different look
than jack ryan yeah i mean i think uh
i think you know john is like the
execution arm
you know of of of uh of jack ryan you
know he's a little more
uh physical even though john's been
doing a great job i mean uh
kaczynski's been doing a great job you
know portraying he's been you know in
the mix getting
you know full of action you know on the
on the show that he's been doing
but i i think john's a little bit more
uh you know
straightforward in his approach and uh
and wanting to you know you know honor
the genre
and really and really bring that you
know that that uh
energy and excitement and adrenaline to
this action thriller uh so we found ways
to put you know john kelly in positions
to really show that you know and and
and you know without losing the drama
and the stakes
and the you know the the character and
the hurt that he's kind of went through
or that that he goes through and uh we
just all want to bring that all in one
package you know tightly knit uh origin
store yeah and you guys i think
very successfully did that especially
with the cash you assembled to bring it
together but i have to ask you looking
back on i went back
you just seem to like want to make it
really difficult for yourself
as far as training because i'm just
looking back i'm like man he's really
making it to where every single time he
does this between creed and now this
it gets very physical so is this a
harder muscle to flex for this kind of
like gun
weapons training versus like getting
ready for creed like which is worse are
they about the same
uh i i think this one was just
sheer volume and scope of the stunts and
the amount that we
we had in this one would probably put
this at the top
as far as the you know the most
difficult so far
uh i mean you know the next one rainbow
six maybe you know
we'll try to see if we can outdo
ourselves but uh for this one
these are the movies that you know i
love watching you know i always wanted
to to do a project like this that i have
to train
relentlessly to do different stunts you
know whether it is you know jumping
inside of a burning car
or underwater work which is the first
time i actually kind of dived into that
into that space
uh you know a lot of weapons training
explosives uh you know there's a lot of
things
uh that can go wrong uh but
i enjoy it i you know it's fun
so just uh no you're young the gamer
yeah the only young one uh is it the
gamer in you that wants to do the
shooting because we know you're an avid
gamer and i had to figure that was
maybe maybe your introduction tom clancy
i don't know yeah no i mean well
i mean it is you know rainbow six the
video game growing up was definitely my
introduction to the
title you know tom clancy for sure um
and you know my dad
being you know you know marine you know
growing up you know
it you know i've always kind of had that
that type of you know militant you know
kind of uh environment so to be able to
uh you know dive into this uh the space
was was a lot of fun
and i know you're not going to be able
to say it but if
eric killmonger was going to be in
something like
what if as it's rumored and there's this
idea that that character come back would
that be something you'd be excited for
because i know you're not gonna tell me
if it's really gonna happen i mean yeah
i'd be excited for that i think that's a
character that you know
people uh connected with and enjoyed so
um yeah i think i would be excited for
something like that so does that mean
you and ryan
i'm just hoping y'all are going to try
and make a scorsese
sort of de niro or scorsese and dicaprio
pairing is that the plan going forward
we all just keep doing as
many as possible yeah i mean i enjoy
working with ryan you know
we we started you know something
together you know years ago
and and and you know that's like family
to me so
you know the goal the goal i mean the
goal and the hope is to you know
continue to make movies that you know
that mean something
and um you know continue that
relationship moving forward
you know we're just we're both
individually very busy you know and just
trying to find the right time to like do
that
is uh is challenging but you know you
should definitely look forward to seeing
more things from us
has it occurred to you that perhaps john
kelly
has done something we can't it's really
great to see you
do this sort of like spy thrillery stuff
i feel like um
i've been sort of like a fan of all of
your stuff but i like it when you get a
little dark
um talk about re-teaming with michael v
jordan and how you sort of came about
the project as a producer was it like
him texting you
hey man what's up i mean
not not too far off actually about that
um
but um no i will say this you know
obviously michael worked together
a few years ago now i think like 2014 or
2015 or something
and um in those intervening years as we
all know that michael's trajectory has
just been up
up up up global movie star phenomenal
you know
everything else beacon of the industry i
would say so
going into it i was like you know as you
can imagine i was a little bit like
what's this guy going to be like now you
know like what's how is this guy gonna
what's how has he changed how is this
affecting him
and um you know i'm not just blowing
smoke because that would be an easy
thing to do
um you know because he's my producer and
everything but um
but i was so enamored by him i was so
enamored by his ethics
so enamored by his commitment the way he
doubled down
in terms of his dedication to his work
um the way he lifts
everybody up around him how he carries
his own identity with his own projects
how he's producing now this is coming
through his own company i mean it's just
you know it's um
it's beyond impressive it's it's like
it's what we should all aspire to if you
know if you're in the industry and you
have an interest in making films and
having more
authorship of what you do it's just it's
what you aspire to be and i very much
aspire to be someone like michael in the
way that he's he's he's governed himself
within the industry so
i don't think you should sell yourself
short i mean you've been doing this for
a little bit
and i think if there's anyone that could
maybe with your time you know
a similar situation you know shot into
the stratosphere very early and a lot of
people
probably telling you things you're here
you can evaluate and you've probably
seen some people
go straight astray so it's very uh
completely you know [ __ ] it up
basically and um and uh
you know my michael is he's uh he's
aware of that you know he's aware of
what he
what his currency is and what it means
and what he can do with it
and um i'm just uh incredibly impressed
and
uh you know i i i want it for myself so
like so so i see that and it's an
example for me you know that's the way i
see it i love that
i will say your character is not this is
not his first appearance in the
tom clancy versus he's actually sort of
a connective tissue character similar to
john kelly slash john clark
um talk about that i mean were you
familiar with the whole tom clancy
universe
did you want to assuage all of the other
uh performances so they didn't
affect you or did you want to lean into
it you know i'm a child of the the
mid-80s so like i i kind of really did
grow up with a lot of reruns of this
of the of the clancy stuff on tv in
english television you know
humphrey october is probably my favorite
but i also grew up with patriot games
and clear and present danger and all
that stuff
and um so i you know i when i when i saw
you know it's a clancy movie like i have
that cinematic legacy in the back of my
mind like oh
this feels like folkloric um
cinematic language that i want to be a
part of and um
uh and the part like obviously i've seen
this at other iterations of this
character
by other actors and stuff i've been
immensely impressed with
how those other actors have portrayed
him who's you know he's a slippery
character this guy
i think the difference with this version
of it is that he's very much someone who
not only exists in dc as someone who's
pulling the strings behind the curtain
but he's also
on the front lines he's someone who will
pick up a weapon and he's right next to
john kelly
in some of these missions so that
element to the character felt new
to me and i liked that i got to be
physical with him as well as um
playing all the subterfuge and playing
all the lies and everything else that
goes on with him so
there was a lot for me to do here and i
was very excited about it
yeah not to give too much away but your
character definitely is
one on screen where like you just don't
know where their loyalties lie which is
perfect for a spy thriller like you
definitely are always like
what's this dude about very little
finger in game of thrones if you will
give me the analogy
but one person who was not having you
from the get
is jody turner smith her character was
like
i don't like you what was it like you
two going toe-to-toe because that was
actually some of my more favorite scenes
was her just being like uh-uh
i don't like you man yeah yeah yeah yeah
so listen like me and jody like
her hotel room was like right next to
mine and we became
i didn't know before this um and i was i
spent many dinners with her and her
husband joshua and
um we got to know each other really well
and um
you know she was she was going through
something at the time of making this
movie as well
you know and um she's a warrior man like
she's a
warrior she's a um
phenomenal force and also like remember
she's playing
this you know as much as we think of
john kelly as this formidable
fighter her character is the only one
that can get him to
listen to her and that requires
incredible force
incredible aptitude and incredible um
authority
and i think she does that really well in
this movie she's also representing women
in the armed forces
in this movie um incredibly
underrepresented in films she's playing
a navy seal
uh as well which is the pinnacle of the
armed forces and also she's in a
position of power so it's like um
i love jody i loved all of our scenes
together so much and
um you know uh it was it was it was
really fun
to have her as as a friend on this movie
um
we really got along really well and um
yeah
i would love to do more scenes with her
for sure no she's incredible and another
person who i think is
on that same like stratospheric you know
push
right now and so i'm just so excited to
see what she uh
could do next this is more of a
frivolous question but
this is a spy thriller and i'm a bit
nosy so
is there anyone you would want to spy on
like i would want to see what
the obamas are doing right now or like
what beyonce does in a day
oh good i don't think i can beat those
ones like
there's all the people yeah you're right
like i just want to know like what's
michelle's
morning routine you know like like is
she what's she doing in the mornings
is it coffee first i know she likes she
what else is she doing i mean i i want
to know all that stuff
i want to know like what's that version
of netflix and chill
you know i'd love to know what that is
like i mean maybe it's
i don't know maybe because i'm talking
to a brit another one i fantasized about
was
any member of the royal family while
they watched the crown i would just like
to be a fly on that wall
just to watch what their faces take
immense anxiety
i know four things four things um
it seems like you are a fan of the tom
clancy series is there one particular
film that really stood out for you as as
the pinnacle maybe the one in the back
of your mind you're like okay
we got this to sort of like compete
against or perform
you know red october for me is is the
one
it's the one uh because as yeah you know
obviously and uh young baldwin
um but also i'm just a sucker for
submarine movies i know that makes me
like really nerdy
and really um you know bro in a way
but also can i give you a recommendation
to watch on that yeah
yeah so this um there's a documentary i
think it's a british documentary it's
called last breath
and it's about a guy who does like deep
saturation diving
in the midst of a storm and it all goes
wrong like it all goes
the worst it could possibly go and it's
just it's unbelie it's a story of
survival it's a story of
teamwork and and coming together against
adversity and
i really it's an if if you want to
netflix and chill
watch the last breath their plan is a
series of strategic attacks
all over the world we have to respond
i need to be on that team lieutenant
commander greer you lead the mission
jody congratulations first of all they
kind of warned me
that you were like grace framed by
beauty in paradise but
girl that is a setup
oh my god thank you
well it's a bit of a departure for this
movie let's be honest because it is dark
and you are very much taking it to a lot
of men
within it and i kind of want to start
there because
your character first of all you know
she's navy seal
jamie talked about how you're really
representing
women in the military and you're taking
it
to both his character and michael b
jordan's character pretty much for the
entire run
so talk about how you approached it and
how much fun you had telling the sexiest
man alive to shut up and listen
lots of fun and you know
i really appreciate it i wanted to feel
grounded and real and human
and i also wanted to have a certain
sense of knowledge about
what an individual who has who plays the
role that she does in real life
and what that kind of person is like
and so it was really important to me to
try to meet someone
who does her job who lives that life
and when i got to meet this person and
kind of see this personality and
they express themselves i was like wow
sensitivity
kindness openness that's all part of it
and so i really sought to bring that to
my character as opposed to
i think oftentimes women in these roles
are told they need to subvert those
parts of themselves but i thought no
let's like lean into that instead of
strength i think that's important too
because when you look at black women
they're so
the catalyst of everything that happens
in this story both
from john's tragedy to you essentially
pushing him
to try and do the right thing to try and
you know sort of honor that
and but let's be honest you're right
there's a vulnerability to it and
there's a closeness to it and a huge
authenticity to it
but you still had to be like a military
person and so you had to like train for
this
like where were you on that part because
girl you just had a baby like
where were you when all this i was just
like this must have been a lot of
training
pretty quick to that i would imagine
yeah no i was pregnant while i was doing
this i was in my second trimester
yeah oh my gosh so it was intense you
know but i still
i was i trained i watched it you know i
went to the trainer i was working with
the military guys that we had on set
you know we were doing i was doing
weapons training i was doing everything
that i could
to bring as much fantasy to this as was
possible
you know i was trying to train up the
men in what it meant to deal with a
woman who was pregnant
that was probably the hardest part oh
girl tell me tell me were they trying to
be too nice to be like sit down
they don't get it no they weren't trying
to be too nice i don't understand i
think men just think they're like oh you
i am pregnant it's fine you just added
up they don't they don't get it
they don't know that's fine because i
don't know
what they're understanding they may not
understand that
how
how important it is and how literally
everything is like my organs are almost
you know whatever
yeah it's transformation
of your entire body to give life yeah
well you gave life to that as well as
you cultivated this incredible
performance which jamie was had nothing
but incredible things to say about you
he talked about you guys got very close
during the filming of this
but also he's my boy
jamie was like are you jamie with my
comic really
he's hilarious i love him i only got him
for a few minutes in the zoom but i can
totally
i would say agree with you on that he's
infectious the minute you get to talk to
him
but you're surrounded by that i mean it
feels like everyone in this was just so
incredible
but talk about michael and how as a
producer he approached you i would
imagine
about the role and you definitely met
him very early on in the process so yeah
talk about
him and and was this the first time you
guys had met yeah well no we met
at a potty before that like what i was
doing right before i went to go do queen
and slim was the first time i met
michael
wow so talked about approaching the role
yeah actually actually no i
was it before i had done it was before i
jumped in and said we met
actually but yeah no i think i think
michael was just excited to see what my
take was gonna be on it you know he
really let me just like do my thing in
the sense he didn't kind of come and say
like you know you need to do this we
need to do that he just kind of like
really let me do my thing in this and
you know michael's wearing so many hats
i think it's admirable
the way that he is pushing for the
things that he's pushing for in our
business and the way that he's making it
his mission
to be inclusive on his sets you know
so yeah what he does with outlier is
incredible
you know one of the first studios to put
inclusion riders in as a mandate for
their production capabilities which they
already were but to put that out there
the way they did
is absolutely incredible and you can
tell based on the cast that he assembled
um
slightly frivolous here though because i
know that you've had
two very different like this is the
second chapter for you because you
already had another career in another
industry
and i'm just curious without remorse
when i told people i was doing it the
first thing they thought was
if they didn't know the book they were
like what is this is about regrets and
it made me wonder
is there anything in your you know
histories already as a career
have you had remorse in the sense of
like you knew
that this was definitely the right
decision that maybe at the time you
didn't and now you look back on it like
no regrets
or something that you did turn down and
you
absolutely knew it's like this is just
not where i need to be
so anything in your career that you look
back on now like without remorse
i mean honestly i look back on
everything without remorse
wow you know what i mean because i think
that
whether something works or it doesn't
work
like i learn something and that is what
i take with me into the next thing
it's like i everything is an opportunity
for expansion
look it's not always gonna be what you
thought it was gonna be and it's not
always gonna come out perfect
you know that is life but like the key
is it's like are you learning
did i learn something did it expand me
you know and when i can look at it that
way when i can live life not thinking
about like i regret that
it just gives me that much more
opportunity for growth because when i'm
in regret then i'm in shame about
something
you know that's a great way to be and i
guess that's the best way to be because
looking at
your career like when we first spoke for
queen and slim i was like listen
y'all clock it this is going to be a
person we're going to be seeing a lot of
and you've completely
fulfilled all that thoughts and two
things you have coming up one
which is very recent and then the other
one which folks are going to see soon
and berlin and borderlands like girl
let's just talk about your career
already you've made so many great
choices so
you're talking about after yang you
can't forget about after yeah
yeah same same i mean we're calling
charles directed by sonata
i'm really excited for that project to
you know
anne boleyn you know that was such a
wild experience
you know when i went i went over to the
uk my daughter was just five months
still nursing and it was like every
three hours i was like at the pump or
nursing home and it was so intense do
that
working mothers are my heroes
because honestly to do that
oh my god netflix did this like video
like dedicated to working mothers and i
literally cried when i watched it i
don't know if you ever saw this video
yes
yes but it does it made me weep you know
every woman oh my god i want to cry just
thinking about it but like
you know women pumping in in closets and
doing whatever they can
just so that they can like you know
make it happen they took everything from
me
uh first of all i have to say taking the
job i'm sure it wasn't like they had to
convince you long to be with michael b
jordan but then they're like oh and
you're going to be
so heavily pregnant so
did that make you like want a second
thought because i know those pregnancy
suits are not
the best and most fun to act you know
no that they actually are nothing
compared to actually
being pregnant and so i have two
children of my own
and i know very well what that feels
like
you know that wasn't um i didn't really
take that into consideration
as much as i did um was i even ready
to do it at all that's so
surprising because watching it and
this is a part that i think you know if
it wasn't written as the way it was
written or
what you guys didn't do on screen was so
felt so lived in
it wouldn't have been what it was
because she's such the emotional
catalyst of everything
that john does after that and it could
have just been like this flat thing but
that scene of y'all in the bedroom where
you kick him out which we know
if you watch the movie is very important
to the storyline that's where i felt
those two were so
lived in so yeah just talk about working
with michael on that scene because
it's like everything after that has to
pay honor to that moment
yeah we um you know mike is actually was
a good friend
of mine and so we we knew each other
before we
uh worked together so that was a plus
just being able to work with
someone you consider a brother and you
hold at such high regards
and vice versa you know i think we have
a lot of respect for each other and i've
been saying this which is just the truth
is that you know once you've experienced
life to a certain level you kind of have
you you kind of know where that
tenderness and that love comes from and
you just bring that
to your heart and i think that um being
feeling feeling safe and um
respected by mike had a lot to do with
um
being that comfortable on in those
scenes i appreciate that
and again you can definitely see it
within it of course this is a spy
thriller so forgive me i'm just going to
be a little
a little nosy now is there anyone you
would want to spy on this doesn't have
to be anyone in your life like i would
just like to watch
i would like to watch beyonce go through
a day
just for fun like what does she get to
do
so maybe not like invasive spine was
there anyone you'd like to
peek behind the curtain on dinner with
the obamas i don't know
no i don't um
you're a better person i don't you know
i um
i would like to peek in on myself hey
that's profound right there whoa
actually that's like the better thing
like if you could see yourself in your
own movie i'm taking that one i'm not
gonna lie that is so much better than
that
you can have it it's for you i'm like
i'm that
let me not be messy for once and like
take something
from this question um something that is
celebratory and not necessarily about
without remorse but
definitely something i want to talk to
you about is the fact that all of those
shows went to netflix have you had
the resurgent from the gay because
everyone i've talked to those one of
those shows told me they're like
girl i didn't people in like london are
coming up to me talking about these
shows that they hadn't seen before did
you feel that when netflix brought
the game and all those shows over that
people were like reaching out
no i i haven't i that might have a lot
to do with just being in quarantine
and not being out um in public
to receive any feedback from anyone
but no i haven't oh well that makes me
sad because girl that was like christmas
well let me give you the love i really
watched everything
all the way through and when i got to
when you showed up i was like yes i
forgot
it was so funny i have to yeah don't say
i
was just telling someone i've i've been
in um disney plus
and um kid movies so all i have is i'm
watching kid movies all the time
you know what though that's fair though
there's some good kid movies on disney
plus though because like you can
introduce your kids now to like the
stuff you used to watch that's like
yeah but my people are into it they're
like the animation is old i'm like what
yeah you know the animation has changed
so much what are they shooting down i'm
sorry we're just gonna go ahead and
bring this down what are they not naked
aladdin i know
that is so you know what you're raising
them right now showing it to them though
i appreciate you showing it to them um
obviously
this story is an extension of the tom
clancy universe which has
been around for a while like again it's
not like i think everybody was reading
his books at least i wasn't i was too
young but
i was watching the movies i remember ben
affleck i remember harrison ford is
there one of the tom clancy's that you
had seen before
or liked i mean you got i think the best
leading man so
sorry harrison no i wasn't as familiar
as everyone else um
you know i'm a very old school girl i
still watch waiting to exhale
and boomerang so cia doesn't support any
further investigation into your wife's
murders
[Music]
i have to kind of say like tom clancy
it's a universe at this point and
there's like so many
different iterations uh before joining
this one and did you have a favorite
i'm imagine this one's your favorite now
now of course this one it's my favorite
i mean i was a big fan
more or less of all uh the movie that
were made
by tom clancy and then i'm
a huge fan of him of tom clancy
and this is the reason why i love the
idea to
create uh to participate and
creating the origin story of
john kelly that i feel is john clark
at the end it is one of the most
interesting characters that was
not really explored
until now and i like him because it's a
little bit more
dark than all the other character
that lives in the tom clancy universe
let's say
i like uh his uh ability
to be to live in
in his shady
kind of uh approaching his gritty and
brutal approach that is different from
jack ryan of course yeah it's definitely
more operating in the shades of gray
as far as like loyalties and who are the
good guys and who are the bad guys
um what's interesting too is you know
this is you reuniting with
uh taylor sheridan and i'm just curious
what about the way that he writes
because i've heard this from a lot of
folks both the directors that he's
worked with
and the folks that have worked with him
as a director he has a very specific i
would say cadence to his screenplays and
how they
sort of play out um and and essentially
feel very like for his western stuff but
this one feels very much almost like a
throwback
to those 80s sort of russian spy things
but it's updated and that's the same
thing with the western so yeah talk
about how
yeah he approached updating the i would
say you know older source material
when i when i first approached to the
without remorse was uh the script was
originally written by
sean reilly the creator of the show
and was of course written in the early
90s so i gave to paramount and to
michael my
pitch on the eventual movie so i asked
taylor to john because i already worked
with them and so i
i know exactly uh what you can
bring the humanity the the
[Music]
really classy and elaborate dialogue
and he pays
a lot of attention on the psychology of
the character that is something that
they really like
so in a completely different way of
course but we have a similar
approach so i thought that i would be
protected by adding
a mountain board and he wrote a
beautiful script
yeah it's really incredible too just to
see how well
it sort of updated um in a way that i
didn't think that you could given like
the enemies are so different
um than they were why do you think
though that that time period is still
sort of enduring like that cold war
sort of you know superpowers um
shady spying why do you think people
still want to revisit that because it
seems to be
something that goes back if you think i
mean the mechanism that is
behind a war
meaning that it's not the word itself
but how you want to have or
why you make a war the mechanisms
are the same if you think a little bit
this
book was written in the 93 set it up in
the 70s
if you watch it today and
try to imagine the last uh scene with
the senator clay
and
we live in a country that is splitted
in two we are fighting one against
the other we need an enemy
yeah he's the best enemy russia
so i mean it's like i think that is uh
is
modern and it works because he's
exactly as it is is uh
it's it's also today
i feel that without you more some a part
an aspect of the movie it's uh
pretty relevant and accurate especially
after uh what's happened in january
yeah no absolutely there's so many
things that i don't think
you could have predicted would hit as
hard as they do
when you were first scripting it and
it's just i guess a sort of um
a testament to the source material but
more importantly what you guys were able
to do to make it feel very timeless and
very applicable no matter what
the new situations are it's a very
interesting
premise too because i'm not gonna lie to
you when i was first telling people
about it and i was like i'm gonna do
without remorse like
that title alone just gets people in in
a way that they're like it like
latches on to them and i had a lot of
people like talking about regret so i'm
just gonna ask this kind of frivolous
one but
is there something that you a decision
that you made
that you look back on and like like this
was without a doubt something that i
don't regret doing because it put me on
the right path
or maybe something that didn't work out
but now looking back on it you're like
no regrets this is 100 the right thing
that should have happened
i think we i mean every time i i try
not to re-watch my movies because i get
really because when i watch it it's like
i feel oh why
we did so i mean why why
i mean it's like somehow it's it's uh
it's always a little bit difficult for a
director to detach
enough because i mean i i've been
working on this for
at least two years three years so it's
like
it's an incredible amount of time so you
are so
deep in that uh i mean sincerely i
cannot
answer the question probably i can do it
in three years from
from now no i get it
uh before we get out of here we of
course have to talk about your leading
man
michael b jordan and i know that he was
you know obviously
the name from very early on but he's
going to be directing his first
film uh pretty shortly here did did you
know that at the time that he sort of
like
recorded a video village yeah we we
spoke about it
yeah yeah i think that michael is
really really smart smart and then he's
a
super nice and kind the human being
that is most of all it's really
important
and then i i think that he has a big
feature in front of him
because it's like uh
he has a lot of quality and he's uh
super nice to work with because he was
uh
even in the movie where he played
basically all the stunt
scene one stuff that was pretty
crazy and challenging for him he was
always smiling with the good energy
around it
so i wish him the best really
because he deserved that they're gonna
play bamaros now
no remorse
you